and pretty much all science fiction
involving interstellar society's war in
combat play at least some role science
fiction authors throughout the years
have created various types of devices
designed for defense or offense weapons
of varying levels of power and degrees
of destructive capability the warriors
of the dune universe have a variety of
weapons to choose from from simple
blades and sores to hand guns which can
fire laser beams
[Music]
Frank Herbert did not often describe
technology and how it worked in great
detail in his dune saga the main focus
of the saga is centered on the themes
and the driving philosophies woven into
the narrative still technology weaponry
specifically has a significant role
among the citizens of the Imperium
throughout the series various kinds of
weapons appear evolving as humankind
evolves in the book dune Paul Atreides
is trained with a number of weapons
Bodkins which were thick and blunt
needles used for piercing cloth or
leather Kindles double-edged blades
similar to the Zippos used to by the
ancient Greeks from which the Atreides
are descended slow pellet stunners which
were projectile weapons that could throw
poison darts Paul was also trained with
swords specifically rapiers a type of
slender large and sharply pointed sword
designed to be a thrusting weapon
Holtzman technology allowed humans to
fold space and communicate across great
distances it enabled shield technology
as well shield technology rendered most
projectile weapons such as slow pellets
toners and mauler pistols obsolete but
such weapons were still used far more
often than last guns because of the
Imperials utilization of the Holtzman
affect the way weapons were used in the
Dune universe was changed forever
laz guns were described in dune as
continuous-wave laser projectors the
weapons were very powerful but the use
of them was extremely limited due to the
Empire's reliance on Holtzman technology
when the beam of a lads gun interacted
with a field generator shield produced
by the Holtzman effect sub atomic fusion
occurred the results were catastrophic
because the use of shields was so
widespread throughout the empire other
types of weapons were typically used
over last guns in order to avoid these
kinds of nuclear reactions before the
time of the god emperor when the
padishah Emperor still reigned most
soldiers preferred the use of swords and
knives in combat when utilized correctly
such weapons could safely penetrate body
shields Duncan Idaho who attended the
genus school trained Paul Atreides in
swordsmanship the swords masters of the
genus school were considered the
greatest warriors in the universe the
best of the impure sardick our soldiers
could match up to a level tin genus
swordsman the craft of swordsmanship was
respected in the Imperium and many of
the Great Houses of the far for Lucius
employed a swords Master of the genus
school on the planet Arrakis however
especially in the desert devices such as
louse guns and mala pistols were more
common since the use of shields was
impossible in the deep desert due to the
maddening effect that the Holtzman
effect had on the great worms of dune
the freeman who lived their lives
roaming the deep desert often made use
of mala pistols which could fire darts a
considerable distance the Fremen also
made use of blades called Kriss knives a
Kriss knife was a blade carved from the
tooth of a dead sand worm these weapons
were sacred to the Freeman once the
blade was drawn blood must be shed
it was also forbidden for an outsider to
lay eyes upon an unsheathed blade the
Freeman would also often poison the tips
of the blades hunter seekers were an
extremely dangerous and very common
assassination weapon used among the
noble houses of the Imperium the
children of nobility learned about such
devices at very young ages the device
would be operated from another location
and depend upon motion detection to see
its target once a target was detected
the device would burrow directly into
the targets closest vital organ killing
them instantly
immediately after the but Larian jihad
when all thinking machines have been
destroyed the rulers of the Imperium
converged to form the great convention a
treaty which reserved the use of Atomics
for a nonhuman entity the agreement said
that due to the catastrophic history
that nuclear weapons had among human
society humans would never use such
weapons on each other but instead on
non-human threats should they ever
appear only the Great Houses would be
allowed to possess Atomics henceforth
the great convention stated use of
Atomics against humans shall be cause
for planetary obliteration in the book
dune Paul Atreides finds somewhat of a
loophole he uses Atomics not on humans
but to blast a whole
the shield wall of Arrakeen after Paul
became Emperor the Imperium adherence to
the great convention had lessened
considerably Atomics had not been the
only weapons prohibited by the great
convention but all weapons of mass
destruction including stone burners
stone burners were terrible weapons
which not only caused great destruction
but released a type of ray that
destroyed the eye tissue of anything
within several miles a stone burner
detonated at the core of a planet would
cause a reaction leading to the total
destruction of the world the weapon
worked by harnessing atomic energy it
would create fusion setting off an
atomic source and absorbing the sources
energy it would create a disastrous
result the assassins Handbook and in a
universe work supposedly contained a
compilation of commonly used poisons
permitted during the war of assassins
and the weapons which were permitted as
well the war of assassins referred to
the form of warfare that was allowed
under the great convention the spacing
guild also helped maintain peace the
guilds monopoly on space travel meant
that they could deny access to those
that were disruptive 5,000 years into
the saga by the time of the honoured
matras the guilds monopoly on space
travel had been broken and the great
convention was no longer honored the
matras utilize a weapon possessing
tremendous power when activated it
created a blast of incredible heat
capable of scorching the surface of
entire worlds the honored mot Ray's
brought the weapon out of the scattering
and intended to use it to subdue the
Binnie Jesuit sisterhood many science
fiction writers tend to agree that war
is a part of human nature even thousands
of years in the future humankind still
must contend with its self-destructive
disposition the timeline of the dune
saga indicates that humankind has some
difficulty evolving past these patterns
and even though peace can be maintained
for some time society tends to trend
towards violence the honored MOT Ray's
represent a version of the many Jesuit
who had lost their way surrendering to
their most volatile instincts and
undoubtedly setting themselves on a
clear path
for annihilation thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you like and
subscribe if you enjoyed the content and
if you want to support this channel
click the patreon link in the
description